[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizamos las claves de este año
2022 marcado inevitablemente por la
guerra en Ucrania que estalló a finales
de febrero el conflicto ha marcado un
antes y un después a nivel geopolítico y
también económico Qué consecuencias le
esperan a la Unión Europea cuando pronto
se cumplirá un año desde que empezó la
invasión lo abordamos con nuestros
invitados el eurodiputado del grupo de
Los verdes arnés hurtason bienvenido
arnés Hola qué tal Y con la eurodiputada
del grupo renovar Europa evapoch
bienvenida Eva Muchas gracias Me
gustaría empezar con una pregunta para
los dos la otan y la Unión Europea han
advertido que hay que prepararse para
una guerra larga o que incluso se
convierta en un conflicto congelado está
la Unión Europea preparada realmente
para un conflicto largo y para sus
consecuencias de arnés
bueno se ha ido preparando un poco a
marchas forzadas Es verdad que la guerra
expuesto toda una serie de debilidades
muy grandes de la Unión Europea opciones
de política energética exterior durante
muchísimos años equivocadas con
dependencias a los combustibles fósiles
externos que nos han llevado a una
situación Pues que ha provocado mucha
inflación que ha provocado pues una
tensión en la presión de energía muy
fuerte y desde luego no estábamos
preparados no pero bueno la más allá de
lamentarnos de las decisiones que se
tomaron de forma equivocada y que
nosotros como verdes denunciamos durante
mucha mucho tiempo creo que pensar cómo
reaccionamos ahora no yo creo que la
solución más importante que debemos
tomar es avanzar lo más rápidamente
posible en recuperar una cierta
soberanía energética en base a un
despliegue mayor de la renovables que es
lo que nos puede permitir es ganar esa
Independencia energética y combatir la
inflación porque al final la inflación
es una inflación fósil provocada por
nuestra dependencia de los combustibles
fósiles Y eso es lo que tenemos que
hacer lo más rápidamente posible en los
próximos años de eso hablaremos en unos
minutos de ARN
que piensas que realmente la Unión
Europea está preparada pues como dijo
Ernesto que hemos dado pasos importantes
para prepararnos por ejemplo cuando
vemos las reservas de gas de los estados
miembros estamos ya 94% más o menos lo
que me preocupa más bien es el invierno
que viene si estamos yendo hacia una
guerra larga por eso Por ejemplo estamos
trabajando en adaptar los fondos de
recuperación a esta crisis energética a
través de lo que llamamos re Power you
que es otro instrumento para que los
estados miembros puedan invertir en
infraestructuras energéticas ahora corto
y medio plazo lo que me preocupa más
bien es la ayuda macrofinanciera a
Ucrania eso es un punto muy importante
hasta ahora hemos podido como Unión
Europea dar una ayuda macroeconómica muy
importante a Ucrania básicamente sabemos
todos que la guerra les cuesta muchísimo
muchísimo dinero y solamente digamos
sobreviven como país con las ayudas que
por fuera no por nuestra parte por parte
de Estados Unidos pero ahora Estamos
viendo como por ejemplo Hungría está
vetando estas ayudas entonces me parece
que ahora también es el momento parece
que no para algunos pero sí que es el
momento para abordar esta cuestión de
cómo tomamos de forma más eficaz estas
decisiones y no nos podemos permitir que
un país vete la ayuda económica a
Ucrania que es tan importante hay que
acabar con la unanimidad hay que acabar
con la universidad y el parlamento
europeo ha sido clarísimo en esto y no
solamente nosotros como parlamento
europeo sino Este ha sido el resultado
de la conferencia sobre el futuro de
Europa donde además hicimos paneles
ciudadanos con muchísimos ciudadanos y
este era uno de los resultados hablamos
de competencias de la Unión Europea la
Unión Europea tiene muchísimos
competencias en muchos sectores que
simplemente no puede ejercer porque el
procedimiento de toma de decisiones no
nos lo permite porque tenemos vetos de
de Estados individuales
Antes estabas comentando la crisis
energética vemos que la Unión Europea ha
reducido ahora ya drásticamente la
dependencia del gas ruso pero a cambio
hemos ampliado la energía nuclear se
quema carbón también Incluso se ha
ampliado en algunos países se importa
más ganas gas natural licuado de países
como
Qatar se pueden entorpecer la lucha
contra la crisis climática justamente
por la crisis energética Bueno eso es
algo que nos preocupa no no voy a decir
que no nos preocupe esto porque es
verdad y en la cop 27 Europa fue fue
sujeto a críticas numerosas porque es
verdad que estamos sustituyendo a una
parte del gas que importábamos por hemos
reiniciados la producción de carbón en
algunos países y estamos otra vez
Incluso en algunos de los proyectos que
algunos estados miembros tienen para
recuperar la soberanía energética vemos
incluso planes de construcción de
infraestructuras fósiles no lo cual a
nosotros nos pone los pelos de punta
porque nosotros muy comprensivos con las
medidas a corto plazo de emergencia que
se tengan que tomar es decir la energía
tiene que llegar a la economía tiene que
llegar a los hogares Y es verdad que
algunas decisiones dolorosas Quizás sí
tienen que tomar Pero es verdad que
vemos también en paralelo que hay una
cierta reversión de Los criterios del
New deal tratando de utilizar este
momento para atarnos a los combustibles
fósiles más a largo plazo con
dependencias exteriores nuevas
permanentes y con algunos proyectos de
infraestructuras fósiles dentro de la
Unión Europea que no compartimos para
nada no es decir yo creo que como verdos
para nosotros el equilibrio es medidas
de emergencia Sí pero que sean
temporales con un límite muy claro en el
tiempo y ese es un poco el debate que
tenemos también en el reverío que
mencionaba Eva pero nosotros no estamos
de acuerdo en que se utilice esto para
volver a cometer los errores del pasado
que eso es volver a tener dependencias
exteriores y dependencias en
combustibles fósiles Y eso vemos algunas
algunas actuaciones y algunas propuestas
que nos preocupan francamente
los precios de la energía están muy
altos menos que hace unos meses pero
siguen muy altos respecto hace dos años
la comisión europea está a la altura
porque ha sido muy criticado sobre todo
por cuestiones como con sus reticencias
en el límite al precio del gas pues sí
sí que me parece que la comisión ha
estado a la altura justo por eso o sea
por lo que algunos la critican porque la
comisión europea digamos no ha aceptado
este argumento que me parece un poco
simple y populista a veces pues
simplemente hacemos un tope del gas y
los problemas se acaban sino que ha
mirado exactamente lo que ha pasado por
ejemplo en España y lo que ha pasado en
España es que el consumo ha aumentado
entonces la comisión europea sí que lo
ha criticado y lo que ha dicho es que si
hacemos este tope el gas lo que tenemos
que mirar que no aumente la demanda de
gas porque esto también en términos
ecológicos no es lo que precisamente
queremos y en términos de dependencia de
también el gas ruso etcétera lo que está
también otra cosa que tenemos que tener
en cuenta es a ver si vamos a
subvencionar ahora por parte de la Unión
Europea el gas que se puede utilizar en
otros países como por ejemplo que tienen
interconexiones con Unión Europea Como
por ejemplo Suiza o el Reino Unido
tenemos que mirarlo todo esto muy bien y
también tenemos que ver lo que se está
haciendo en otros estados miembros por
ejemplo en Alemania pues no se está
interviniendo en el mercado
energético de una manera tan tan
intrusiva no sino lo que se está
haciendo es subvencionar el consumo
digamos los precios elevados de la
factura de las personas está viendo lo
que las personas han consumido por
ejemplo el mismo periodo el año pasado
cuando los precios no estaban disparados
está subvencionando eso de esta manera
no está interviniendo en el mercado
eléctrico y no se está produciendo una
Un aumento de la demanda
es una propuesta ya hablaron los
ministros de finanzas de la zona Euro
esta semana justamente una propuesta que
igual podría aplicarse a arnés las
consecuencias económicas lo comentabas
antes debido a la alta inflación El
Banco Central europeo ha subido los
tipos de interés pero es una medida
adecuada porque tiene evidentemente
también un coste también para los
hogares No yo no comparto la subida de
tipos que está haciendo el Banco Central
europeo de hecho los propios servicios
del bce
indicaron que la subida de tipo ser una
medida que no permitía atajarro que es
un shock de oferta fundamentalmente
energético Y eso no lo puedes atajar con
uno con un aumento con un encarecimiento
el precio del dinero y por lo tanto creo
que el vc está tomando decisiones que
son más me responden más a la presión
política que tiene y que creo que lo
único que va a hacer va a ser empeorar
las cosas porque puede lanzar a la zona
Euro a una recesión y estamos a las
puertas del mismo no con lo cual no
comparto esa decisión y otra cosa que me
preocupa es el reparto de los costes de
la inflación no yo creo que no estamos
teniendo un reparto justo de los costes
de la inflación esta semana sale un
informe del banco de España que señala
que los beneficios empresariales han
aumentado en el último año siete veces
más que los salarios
creo que eso nos está llevando a que los
recortes los repartos de la inflación
nos está produciendo mayores
desigualdades dentro de la Unión Europea
en algunos países y eso debe ser
corregido inmediatamente no con lo cual
yo apoyo completamente la
reivindicaciones de los sindicatos de
que los salarios se ajusten de forma
adecuada y también tenemos que tomar
medidas porque es verdad que sectores
económicos que están teniendo unos
beneficios muy extraordinarios debido a
esta situación el sector energético pero
no solo y por lo tanto la fiscalidad y
debe intervenir para ajustar ese
desequilibrio no Y eso poco a poco lo
hemos ido haciendo y estoy contento que
la comisión europea haya abierto Pues un
poco la perspectiva de hacer de
entemporar beneficios a las empresas
fósiles que están ganando grandes
beneficios Pero tenemos aún mucho camino
por recorrer no Y ese es uno de los
grandes debates del próximo semestre
Cómo ajustar bien los costes de la
inflación si me permites matizar una
cosa estoy de acuerdo pero que estás
matizando lo que lo que arnés acaba de
decir
yo creo que yo sí que pienso que en
términos de política monetaria es lo que
el Banco Central europea europeo es lo
que puede hacer son los instrumentos que
tiene al alcance subir los intereses
para Digamos
si es verdad que no es una crisis que
está Solamente causada la crisis de la
inflación por una demanda excesiva pero
sí que viniendo del cómic sí que y
también y digamos de los fondos de
recuperación sí que hay una un contexto
que el Banco Central europeo está
intentando ahora ver cómo lo soluciona
con su vida de los tipos de intereses no
nos queda mucho tiempo pero quería
haceros una pregunta hemos visto cómo
esta guerra ha dado
ha hecho que la Unión Europea aplique
políticas que antes veíamos imposibles
el envío de armas el entreno de las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas también se le
ha dado el estatus de candidata a
Ucrania para entrar en la Unión Europea
ha sido la Guerra de Ucrania el campo
que podría haber hecho despertar a la
Unión Europea arnés Bueno es un tópico
la Unión Europea avanza a base de crisis
pero es un tó Se confirma cada vez no yo
creo que la Unión Europea dentro de las
capacidades que tiene está ayudando a
Ucrania de forma acertada creo que
estamos en una dinámica de defensa del
derecho internacional por lo que es una
agresión ilegal y creo que la Unión
Europea está haciendo lo que lo que debe
desde ese punto de vista Pero creo que
es verdad que hemos despertado de con
una nueva guerra en suelo europeo sin
los instrumentos adecuados ni de
política exterior ni materia de defensa
seguimos siendo un continente que
básicamente tiene subcontractada la
subcontratada a la defensa a los
norteamericanos sin unas capacidades
propias y todo esto es un gran debate
que está abierto no Cómo mejorar
nuestros mecanismos de toma de
decisiones en materia política exterior
y vuelvo a la unanimidad que decía Eva
antes no yo creo que ese es otro de los
grandes ámbitos en los cuales lo en
inmunidad Debería ser saltada
necesitamos más agilidad en la toma de
decisiones y la construcción de una
defensa Autónoma europea con capacidades
reales que eso también es otro de los
grandes debates que tenemos ahora mismo
encima de la mesa Eva Ya a punto para
acabar de acuerdo con todo lo que arnés
acaba de plantear es una discusión que
estamos teniendo un poco por una parte
en nuestros intereses geopolíticos que
puede ser ahora mismo en Ucrania pero
también en los balcanes y todo lo que
nos rodea no a las fronteras de la Unión
Europea todos los estos intereses
geopolíticos Por otra parte nuestro
funcionamiento interno no Y esta es un
poco la cuestión que estamos teniendo la
Unión Europea Pues sí se tiene que
desarrollar y Tenemos muchos países en
las fronteras de la Unión Europea que
además desean formar parte de
este de esta comunidad de derechos no
para decirlo así pero también tenemos
que reformar nuestra toma de decisiones
porque si no vamos a tener más y más
vetos y no es la no es la idea pues
Lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo Gracias arnés Eva Muchísimas
gracias por vuestras aportaciones a
ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de Europa hoy Gracias por ver
France 24 en español
[Música]